so i've got a little bit of a theory
that i kind of uh developed over the
years and that is
what got you here is not necessarily
what's going to get you there and more
specifically with startups what happens
is that the culture shifts a lot in the
early stages right
[Music]
thank you so much for being on the show
i really appreciate your time
michael thanks for having me i'm super
excited to be here
i am so excited to learn over these next
20 minutes what it means to scale
businesses to raise venture capital
you've raised over 270 million dollars
yourself of venture capital funds
besides being
an early stage investor through
recursive ventures and you know
being a venture partner at upwest and j
ventures and i ca
if i begin to say everything that you've
done i'm not gonna end there itamar give
me a brief rundown of of who you are
what are you passionate about and let's
move from there absolutely
thanks for asking so i'm an operating
investor which means that i have a day
job during the day
and that is the chief business officer
at life360
a company i helped take public last year
in the australian stock exchange
for a valuation of over 600 us million
dollars
um and at night and on weekends i manage
recursive ventures
which is a seed fund that i've raised
myself
and i've been investing in startup
companies at the pre-season
seed stage for the last uh eight or nine
years
incredible okay hold on what is chief
business officer i know what a chief
executive officer a chief financial
officer what is the chief business
officer
so i think it's a little bit up for
interpretation different companies uh
use that title sparingly for different
things specifically for life 360 being a
consumer business a b2c business
i'm really the person that manages most
of the business development
opportunities with different partners
creating an ecosystem of you know
partners and other parties that want to
engage with us
and also doing what's called corporate
development which is mostly m a
and that's you know us acquiring uh
potentially smaller companies to sort of
expand our product line or help with our
you know talent
uh in the company incredible so you know
you're moonlighting as a seated as a
precedent investor yet you're running
you're helping formulate business
propositions and m
a's for companies that go public like
life 360.
is there a dissonance between the two is
there what
like a dissonance a clear distinction
because
it sounds like two different worlds yeah
it's true actually i do a lot of context
switching but uh
you know really the underlying sort of
thread that connects it all
is is i just love helping entrepreneurs
right so i found
early on in my career that i'm i'm i'm
okay as a ceo i can run a company
but i'm actually better at supporting
ceos supporting entrepreneurs running
companies
so really when it comes to uh when you
think about
value creation entrepreneurship and vc
backed scalable startups often at some
point you'd either think about
fundraising right to basically
accelerate scaling up the business
or you'd think about potentially
acquiring other companies that can help
you sort of do that even faster scaling
the business
or you know you think about going public
or selling your company
and those are places where i think if
you've got a lot of collective
experience across different
like pieces that add up to the startup
ecosystem
whether it's product marketing
technology and of course adding
finance on top of that you can really
add a lot of value when you've got this
processing planner view of
of things and that's really what i bring
to the table because of my vericon being
you know
engineering uh product hands-on
operations
business development and also funding
and finance okay so
you know if you have to guess how many
entrepreneurs have you helped over the
years
um honestly probably hundreds i i have i
have a rule by the way i have a rule
which i'd like to share with you in the
audience
please whenever i engage in with
entrepreneurs i just have so much
sympathy for what they're going through
because i've done it myself
and i just try to find a way to help
even if it's one small thing
i might promise to the founder that i
talk with if you're spending your time
with me you're very valuable that
i'll find at least one way to help you
and hopefully but you can't tell
you can't be with every entrepreneur i
mean your time is incredibly valuable
incredibly scary so how do you choose
who do you work with and who do you not
work with
that's a great question so unfortunately
like other vcs i do have to
filter out so i can focus on what i
think
are opportunities that you know have the
highest propensity
or you know biggest chance to make an
impact
on you know on me as an investor and of
course i'm the founders and on society
right
so i've got to sort of pick and choose
which battles i i want to fight and i do
that you know using the skills that i've
learned as
an institutional obesity from some of
the best in the business when i work in
more than their ventures
i sort of learned how to value the
opportunities and i try to focus my time
on
what i believe is the best opportunities
with that said
i think in in this business in venture
capital you really have to create
value for people around you in your
network you've got to
make an impact also for your companies
so i try to
to do the best that i can and free up as
much time as i can you know manage to
free up
to really uh help people in my network
of course okay so hundreds of
entrepreneurs that you've helped
are there more similarities or
differences
that you've seen because then obviously
everybody's crazy that's like the number
one similarity but but
but more tangibly are there more
differences or similarities
it's funny that you say most
entrepreneurs are crazy i actually think
the best entrepreneurs
are amazing in mitigating risk because
startups are so risky to begin with
that really a lot of good founders what
they know how to do well
is like okay we've got those 10
different risk vectors in our business
how do we reduce it down to one right
because startups are so risky so i think
um i think you know i've seen a lot of
different entrepreneurs and they also
invest in in you know um entrepreneurs
how out here in the bay area and
entrepreneurs across the us with some
focus
on israeli entrepreneurs probably 30 35
of my portfolio is what i call
israeli companies which typically means
that you know uh
they've been they've been started by an
israeli entrepreneur here in the
in the us um is there a specific reason
for that by the way
why that why that focus well first of
all i'm israeli
and i moved to the states a little bit
over 10 years ago
so naturally culturally it's easier for
me to relate to israelis right right
um and also because i believe in the
israeli startup ecosystem i think we're
just getting started
right with israelis back in israel doing
amazing work across different fields
machine learning cyber security
so on and so forth there's so much more
opportunities back in the holy land
that's one and second thing you know
i've seen and i've worked with so many
successful
resourceful creative amazing
entrepreneurs
israeli entrepreneurs here in the us so
i think it's actually an advantage that
i have that i'm you know
pretty easily able to tap into israel
entrepreneurs and sort of help them
scale their companies incredible and
carl and i mean you've you are very
active with both upwards labs and and j
ventures and i'm probably missing a
bunch of others
that are very involved with the israeli
or jewish ecosystem
so so that definitely shows scaling a
startup you know
you're mentioning that you know a lot of
entrepreneurs are saying that they're
able to mitigate the risk
or the various races that they have but
at the end of the day like
99.9 of startups fail so
how do you so so where do you see that
you're seeing a lot of early-stage
entrepreneurs coming in
before even a pre-seed or a seed i mean
most of them are going to fail
what what is the distinction that you
see what are you know the common themes
of those that end up able to raise that
capital that gets them to where they
need to get to or don't
that's a great question so uh there's no
science here
right there is directional thinking and
what you know
me personally and other folks in the
industry believe that works so i think
at the early stages there's three things
that i really want to focus on
which is the quality of the team and how
fit is that team to solve this specific
problem
um tam total addressable market which is
a huge deal for vcs and it should be a
huge deal for entrepreneurs as well
because you don't want to go after
a small opportunity that's not
necessarily vc scalable
and sort of try to to win that way but
all you can
can so cam is is is i think uh
a really important one that
entrepreneurs sometimes miss and should
pay more
more attention to and the last i would
say which is
now is easy for you know investors to
speak up and talk about that
is why they call fundability so you know
how
you sometimes it's really hard to turn
down first reactions
there's something there right if if you
want to succeed
in sort of the vc startup game you've
got to be
fundable and on top of all the other
things that i think about when i think
about investing in precedence
companies i really do have to take into
account whether those these people this
company this
this this story would be able to scale
to
more and more investors that would put
bigger checks into the company to scale
it up
so you so what you're saying is that as
an early stage investor you're looking
at a company you're not
you're not just saying is this company
able to to use my money wisely to get to
a product or to get to their first
customers but are they able to then use
that
momentum and raise their series a their
series b from institutional investors
and and and which is sort of one of the
biggest tests right for
startups are they able to get past that
big first institutional funding
and propel that growth and i think i
think
you know having that funding
and having better and smarter people are
on the table to help you as an
entrepreneur
you know scale your startup is extremely
important
which is why also for me as a vc i
believe that's where vcs can add
most value make sure help make sure that
your companies are well funded
that's probably the single thing that
vcs can
do to help their entrepreneurs most of
course there's many other things but
that would be the first that we're
looking at yeah i just had a fascinating
conversation with
us also somebody from j ventures who's a
who's really
um well known for crisis management and
coming into companies who need help
when they're not able to necessarily
raise another round and maximize the
value of their of their assets
and one of the things that he mentioned
is that the the real value that the
board members and the vcs can provide
as you know grounding the founders and
making sure that they understand
you know the hi in the high level what
they need to do how much funding they
need
how do they raise that funding and make
sure that their product that their
company lives on
what's happening today in terms of of of
raising money because you know as a
young entrepreneur it's very confusing
a lot of people are saying only raise
how much you really need
you know save the equity focus on the
business don't focus on your ego a lot
of others are saying raise as much as
you can because
we don't know what's happening tomorrow
there might be such a thing as covet 19
and you're not going to be able to raise
that funding
from march until until may so so where
are you on the spectrum of thought
probably you know i'm very
entrepreneurial frenzy so i'd probably
say raise as much as you can but not too
much
okay so i i think i think i think having
more capital
to work with and basically enabling you
to have
more room for mistakes and a lot of
startups i mean startups are really
this journey inside the founder and the
founding team's head
like how quickly do you understand how
to position your market
and your your product how to uh how to
brand and sell
and operate and scale your business and
it's really that journey where you have
to learn all those things is the more
the quicker you do it
the the the more value you create right
the faster you create that value
so having more capital enables you to
potentially accelerate
that journey and and that that's of
course is extremely important
but on the other hand having too much
capital and we've seen some of this with
some of the soft
bank uh vision funds you know where
we've seen the situations of over
capitalization
that basically leads to mistakes right
because it's easy to solve problems with
money but often that is not the right
solution for problems
often maybe you have the wrong team
members or you got the wrong business
model
or maybe you've got the wrong go to
market right and
pouring more money on that problem
actually doesn't fix it it masks the
real underlying issue
so raise as much money as you can to
give you as many bullets
in that gun to shoot and aim and try to
hit your target
but not too much that you're kind of
that you can't become
uh undisciplined i think that's i think
that's fascinating this idea that money
can solve a lot of problems especially
early on and it's almost
blind the organization into thinking
into you know masking some of the real
underlying problems because at the end
you want to be lean you want to be
efficient you want to maximize your your
product and not just
you know use money to to you know let's
say i want to get to
a million views on on on this show
i can pay a million dollars for
advertisements to get a million viewers
but it doesn't necessarily mean that my
product is good
or that i'm doing something right it's
not a business you actually lost money
that's right that's not a good business
that's that's definitely not a good
business but if i'm able to do this with
a hundred dollars then it then then we
know that there's something here that
with a million dollars i can actually
scale this in a very healthy way
right when you think about a lot of vcs
these days they're really focused on
scaling up
means that there's already some level of
product market fit maybe it's really
good
and right you need the majority of
capital is when you're really scaling up
like going from five sales people to 50
sales people
that requires investment ahead of time
to really hire those people train them
make them effective right
if you if you're early on in the kind of
the first innings of coming up with your
company whether it's a b2c or a b2b
company
i'd actually say you know it's not it's
not about
the money it's about like really coming
up with your thesis
having an mvp going on getting out there
testing stuff
you don't need 100 people and tens of
millions of dollars to be able to do
that
to get that validation sure so i mean
you've seen quite a few entrepreneurs go
in and scale their product or scale
their business from
five sales people to 50 sales people
what what are the factors that are gonna
sort of make or break your or what do i
need to keep in mind later on this is a
very selfish advice that i'm asking for
now
what do i need to keep in mind these
young entrepreneurs i will attempt to
scale my business
from five customers to 50 customers
that's a very interesting question so
i've got a little bit of a theory that i
kind of
developed over the years and that is
what got you here
is not necessarily what's going to get
you there and more specifically with
startups what happens is that the
culture shifts a lot in the early stages
right
so you know early on it's like two
uh two gals and a dog right uh sitting
in some uh basement maybe and they're
trying to come up with something and
come up with a business plan
and that's that kind of scales all the
way to 5 10
20 people but once you get to a point
where there's like managers and people
reporting to them let's say at the 20 to
30 people range
something breaks something changes with
the culture the lines of communication
become longer and more complicated in
seeking and getting alignment within the
team
takes more energy and that's fine so
there's that breaking point
this is another breaking point somewhere
between the 50 to 80 employee range
where again you've got you know even
longer lines of communication
things are more complicated some you
have 20 people meetings where everybody
has to
nod their heads and say yeah this is
awesome and and then you can get going
so that's another breaking point and
there's typically another one of the 120
to 150 employee range and then you're
like a big company you've got other
company
uh uh problems so one of the things that
entrepreneurs and even investors
sometimes fail to recognize is that the
same set of people that actually got you
from
you know like 10 employees zero
employees to 20
i'm not necessarily going to be the
people that get you from 20 to
60. it requires a different type of
leadership
and you have to you know first of all
reflect on yourself as an entrepreneur
and
on your team and who's really you know
the best person for the job at those
different stages and that that's
something that's now always easy for
entrepreneurs to do as as the business
scaled up
i mean i've heard this quite a few times
there are some points and i believe
michael kaufman from fiverr he he gave
an inspiring talk in one of the
conferences i attended and he mentioned
that at every junction of fiverr he kept
asking himself am i the right see
am i still the right ceo to grow this
company now that we're you know hundreds
or thousands of employees
this is a different company than when we
were a couple of friends in a garage and
just
starting out and and and it sounds like
it's almost an impossible ask
to go to an entrepreneur or a founder
and say hey can you please ask yourself
are you still the right ceo to run this
and if not can you please be honest and
and
and you know go to the side and and let
somebody else leave this
and mikhail is amazing i love mikhail
actually he's one of those people that
it's like it's like the investors dream
of somebody who can start by himself and
then manage a thousand people after an
ipo right
there's people like that but it's not
everybody and you have to really
reflect you know on yourself and
understand i mean even for me it was a
journey when i was younger i was like
yeah i'll be ceo and i'll be the best
ceo ever and and you know that's not
actually true
over time you learn what you're good at
and i'm really good at supporting
entrepreneurs versus being an
entrepreneur myself
so i think that kind of self-reflection
can really go a long way for
entrepreneurs
incredible itamar what what are you
passionate about what what industries
what type of entrepreneur
what really gets you out of bed in the
morning so i'm actually more of a
generalist to be off
to be honest with you i do have specific
uh areas and thesis
that i focus on i invest in consumer
technologies
uh but not like e-commerce and sort of
uh
media more services on the consumer side
i invest in data and machine learning uh
tools and capabilities
all the way across the stack from
infrastructure deploying developing
uh different types of data and machine
learning services to
actually service in financial services
and real estate and other verticals
where you can use data
to disrupt antiquated uh businesses
and then i also do a little bit of a
sort of emerging tech
right where i've dumped them in in stuff
like
mobility for example iot
uh and in other areas and it's
interesting because when i look at my
attraction of success right like my
biggest wins as an
investor um live 360 ipo
uh credible ipo uh rings sold to
amazon for over a billion dollars right
automatic
uh salt and serious except when i think
about some of those opportunities
they weren't thesis driven i sort of you
know recognized a strong
uh entrepreneur pursuing a a great
opportunity
and and kind of learned and adopted in
the process of engaging with them
and and kind of build my thesis on the
go when i did that
that's that's worked really well right
that's that's inspiring
one thing i have to ask you know it
entrepreneurship
a lot of the time a lot of times as a
founder it seems you get a lot of no's
you get a lot of suspicion
you get a lot of rejections right for
every 99 vcs
that say no you might or that say for
everyone we see that says yes you might
get 99 that say no
how can founders get be really open to
to really important advice or be you
know mindful of this advice when
they're constantly hearing rejections
and knows how are how can entrepreneurs
you know filter out the good and the bad
and really take in the important stuff
yeah i think that's a great question and
you know when i think about ceos in
startup companies textile
companies they have two jobs that that
matter most to me one is fundraising and
the other one is creating a vision for
the company that aligns everybody
every you know stakeholder in the
company those are the two most important
things and i think if
if you're not really if you're not the
right person
to raise uh you know capital from
investors
then i think in the early stages you
probably shouldn't be the ceo
right because that's something that the
ceo is expected to do like your team is
counting
so uh it's a little bit salesy to be
honest with you like it's
you have to reach out to a lot of people
it's a process it's like a sales process
right it's a partnership process you're
running for a funding partner for you on
this journey
and and and getting knows is really
important
and and learning from those knows
actually getting
valuable feedback finding ways to get
valuable feedback
finding ways to keep engaging with with
some of the investors who knows maybe it
hasn't worked this time around but it
will work next time
right that could be great and kind of
elegantly being able to
uh build your investors network even
through those nodes
is actually pretty critical for a
startup ceo um
you know one way that that i always chat
about with my entrepreneurs
is often vcs would give you very vague
answers and why they chose not to invest
in your company
and i think your goal as an entrepreneur
is to try to get to the bottom of what's
happening even if it's not something
that's comfortable for you to hear
as a founder right one of the best ways
of doing that is really back channeling
and certainly back to those vc's for the
people that introduced them
and trying to understand if you can get
some some more information
there um another good uh way that i
sometimes uh recommend is
you know it's it's actually pretty good
if you've got two founders in the
meeting with vcs where
one the ceo is just talking because
they're the ones that are really
reading but you know another one could
be in the background so they won't take
notes just like
looking at people's reactions i love
that like what what resonates
what doesn't raise a neck it's really a
different mindset because you're not
pitching you're there to
like really read the reactions in the
room and i've seen that being successful
as well
i love that so much right before we
leave i can't believe 20 minutes are
almost over these always go by
way too fast i need three words that you
would use to describe yourself
can i use uh three words and one emotion
a hundred percent
okay so i
helping entrepreneurs i love it i love
it and when he sent me that emoji
through the email it even it even looked
better but it was much cuter when you
did it in person so uh so thank you
love helping entrepreneurs you know i i
look forward to reaching out as an
entrepreneur myself to get to get some
really important advice
and and you know sending you my slide
deck so i i
just love that we're forming this
relationship and thank you for all the
for all the
inspiring work that you're teaching me
through j ventures
and thank you for being so generous with
your time here
absolutely thanks for being this great
initiative i'm really excited about what
you're doing great leaders all around
and thanks for having me michael thank
you very much tada
stay safe out there bye